on a acheté ça aujourd'hui une denrée
rare depuis plusieurs mois déjà avant de
partir
de famille doit régulièrement faire des
dizaines de kilomètres pour
s'approvisionner en préparation pour
nourrisson une source d'angoisse quasi
permanente ce stress puis tu finis par
15 mois que les parents doivent jongler
avec cette pénurie causée par la
fermeture d'une usine du missigan aux
États-Unis Santé Canada dit continuer de
suivre la situation près et travailler
avec les fabricants quant au
distributeur il se veulent rassurant la
situation tend vers la normale on fait
une approvisionnement quotidien au 1900
pharmacies partout au Québec ce qui veut
dire que c'est un client des parents ce
but vers une tablette qui est vide ou le
produit convoité pas disponible à ce
moment-là premièrement il est possible
qu'il soit livré le lendemain grâce à
nos services mais aussi possible que le
produit se retrouve derrière le
laboratoire rappelle que la chaîne
mondiale d'approvisionnement du
médicament et sous forte pression depuis
plusieurs années
on compose avec des centaines de
pénuries de médicaments on travaille
très fort avec le gouvernement du Québec
avec le palier fédéral aussi pour
trouver des moyens de réinvestir dans la
chaîne du médicament les parents devront
patienter encore un peu on anticipe
retour complet à la normale d'ici
quelques mois ici qui me permettra au
Canada Montréal